oh I'm sorry what did I do I'm going oh
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to super fight oh I hit the
wrong button get close to walls get
points fly through holes and stuff more
points oh I'm not ready wait don't even
know the controls is this supposed to be
a gamepad game my wrist okay hang on a
second everybody my controller ah there
we go it's inverted
I hate inverted no no I'm very dead okay
so this game is like you're flying a
wingsuit and as a wingsuit flyer it's um
- oh my Joel is ready did you guys know
that oh that was not a hole I could go
through I'm gonna try to identify the
holes that I can fly through I don't
like inverted yes yes yes I'm a baller
I'm a shot-caller look at me go whoa
alrighty then where the hell am i oh my
gosh whoa I blacked out I don't know why
I blacked out but I blacked out and down
okay okay alright this game would be
bazan kurz in VR but I'm not playing VR
so let's see what we could do right
about now hang on Oh inverted is weird
oh it's cool can I change that please no
invert you mean vert you mean actually
vert it ah that is somehow worse okay
maybe it was a bad idea okay no I don't
want you to die yet okay
all right let's try this guy okay so now
that we got my bearings about me this
game is pretty cool I almost made that
if I could just stop screaming I think
I'd actually be fine well that's not
gonna happen in a million billion
screaming okay I think I caught some
wind there that didn't work out the wet
bond yeah man I really don't like how
flappy this guy is okay all right come
through for a second pass I gotta come
through for the passes that's it up and
then down up
very nice okay ah beautiful beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful I'm a
beauty okay all right all right all
right
ooh a whole I'm gonna stick my head in
that hole too far down flying into one
of these portals to get a new map oh
okay all right are you sure those trees
ain't portals boo I wasn't paying
attention
I was not I'm sorry okay all right I got
a wonder why this person decided to do
wingsuit then again I don't fully
understand most people that would do the
wingsuit thing considering how many
people died from it I mean I know it's
an adrenaline thing but personally I
like the safety of Leia
I like the safety of lay off okay go
down where's another Hall who wants to
give me a hole that's a weird thing to
shout at the top of my lungs who wants
to give me off so I guess my only
objective here is to try it desperately
to not kill the cavalcade of people that
are tossing themselves out of a mountain
just so that they can trust that I won't
kill them Dandan but it's a it's a
futile gesture
cuz that's all I know how to do
literally all I know how to do is kill
him dead kill him dead Oh
too close too close it's fine it's fine
okay just going real gingerly oh yeah
oh that's the good stuff okay hang on I
see a hole this is not at all
that's a portal oh I found the portal
the portal
I found the portal all right I got this
Oh spicy okay sir new get a hang of it
I'm not getting a good hang of it but
I've got a hang of it I got a hang nail
of it I don't know where I am
this is weird I was just getting used to
the last map and you're gonna throw me
into an ADD backward place like that I I
was fine I panicked I'm the one who
panicked oh boy how am I gonna get out
of this one Batman oh I don't know Robin
how about fly yourself into a mountain
oh no another one of my trucks and kamay
trees are dead oh my fault
I'm Batman I wanted to go through that
hole uh alas that's the tragedy of all
our life I don't know don't oh you were
gonna you did and then you didn't
because I told you not to are you okay
I'm not gonna make it through that hole
but I can make it through this there's a
portal there I see you I'm coming for
you I'm covered for you poor who are you
go think you can hide from me portal the
answer is you cannot this to mortals all
right okay I guess we're here now
another portal all right I'm in a weird
Wimbley world oh geez oh gee oh Jesus
okay all right oh my god that was
beautiful for a fresh hot second and
then I was dead I was extremely up hit
achievement for close call right before
I died is that blood on the mountain is
that mock blood on the mountain you know
I wouldn't be too surprised all my
clones that are throwing themselves so
we we merely down this mountain
you know you'd think that one of them
would have learned from the bone
smacking crunches that they're hearing
that maybe it's such a good idea I don't
see many holes boy I wish I had a hole
oh god it's so scary I just feel like I
just feel like I shouldn't do this
you know whoa oh right into the gap we
go
that's fine gap though oh I'm just gonna
go straight down I don't like this map
I'm going for another I'm dying oh god I
don't know why I decided to send me into
the vomit zone but it did
portal all right okay nope there's
nothing there's nothing there to punch
nothing is this all randomly generated I
would very impressive this is all
randomly generated but alas a hey-zeus
burg did not how is that not a hole that
was such a hole now it's a holiest hole
I've ever hold and I've hold a lot of
holes in my day oh come on give me a
hole ooh I see a portal that's kind of a
hole into another universe oh this looks
familiar
wait no it's purple man now I can never
tell with these purple familiar things
Oh another portal hell yeah Oh brown
proud of grey all right any holes I'm
really good looking for holes I'm
getting better at this
oddly enough you wouldn't think that I'd
be getting better at this knowing who I
am and how good I am at games and such
this is a mistake mistake mistake
mistake
Oh oh my god oh my god I was fine and
that I wasn't fine that was entirely my
fault all right let's try this for a
dose time oh no Paul
oh yeah come on that wasn't a hole
that's a hole I know that hole that's
definitely a hole oh yeah awesome hole
god great hole yeah
just likes to dive um when it runs out
of steam at random moments
oh yeah there's gonna be a good hole
right here it's not a good hole I see
it's a bad hole bad hole bad hole Oh
give me my points you
oh I risk my neck for that I mean I've
killed my neck a thousand times before
this but I risk my neck at that I hope
there's something Oh down okay sweet
moon Oh give me my points you -
bit give me my points I've done so Gucci
I've done so cute Oh Gucci gong or give
me dad portal oh yeah baby okay all
right I like you I like it you you look
like a good one with a nice backside Wow
all right okay I like the way you hole
I got an expert achievement that means
I'm good at this right I see a hole and
a hole
oh come on maybe that that hole
I did so good and then I did not do so
good oh I didn't do there
Oh mate call me bro call me don't hold
me bro dude all me bro Wow
I can't get this hole why can't I get
this hole oh yeah welp I'm dead all
right whole time
oh yeah there we go oh that was a good
hole but it didn't give me the whole
bonus there's a hole oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh that's the spicy made ball oh
I see a spicy meatball oh yeah
oh these are some of the spiciest
meatballs I've ever seen Oh spicy mmm oh
I see a spicy part oh oh yeah oh yeah
that's a spice and at the bow let's see
what we got here oh this feels good
eyes feels real good Oh another portal
all right why not mom mom please
Oh seen this before haven't I
miss dank Oh mistake nailed it nailed it
and nailed it not nailing it Oh oh my
god it's can't believe I'm still alive
we're gonna go for it Oh oh I made it oh
I made it I'm so good I'm so good at
games all right
I'm doing real good I can't believe how
good I'm doing oh this is so fun though
like honestly this game is to the wall
this game is super fun but also
unbelievably terrifying oh my god this
is a mistake oh god damn it I wasn't
even right rank 24,000 really good god
how bad was I oh yeah this was a dead
end
oops I didn't I forgot those a mountain
after the whole slot it yes nail it nail
it nail it nail it nail it nailed it
Oh sick nasty maneuver sick nasty sick
nasty maneuver what sick nasty crash
sick sick nasty disgusting crash like
literally I'm about to vomit
I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get you no I
don't care how many times my neck breaks
I'm gonna get you oh oh oh oh
oh spice
Wow why did that fall there Oh cuz it
didn't have enough air Wow nope okay ha
ha triple score baby triple scored
triple score triple score triple score
it's all about keeping the triples going
those sweet triple o knees o triple baby
Oh God mama quadruple mama quadruple
quadruple they're a cheater cheater what
are you talking about cheater and cheat
nothing unless you're calling about
cheating death oh I went there I
went there to death I went to death this
game is just a this game is incredibly
addicting because I just keep wanting to
jump down this mountain it's super fun
like I'm not lying if this game is super
fun oh man this game is stupid fun don't
do that no no I'll give you speed I'll
give you fuel I'll give you fire I'll
give you that what you deserve oh I
didn't cash out my winnings
gettin greedy yeah okay all right shut
up achievement douchenozzle gonna need
your input on this one oh man I was like
coming out the Deathstar there I've just
been playing silently for a while as it
goes like this is a super super fun like
I just want to get a decent high score
that doesn't quit me in the tens of
thousands of people playing but oh well
alas what can I do but be suck all day
and suck all night
whoa you ask god no ass gone finally
after so much friggin work after being
such an idiot for so long I did I did it
whoa I know less yeah okay alright
that's enough for now I've been playing
this way too long
this is super fun the game is not called
crash the game is called super flight
it's available on Steam I believe and
it's so much fun so thank you everybody
so much for watching check this out in
the description let me know what you
think in the comments and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]